let's talk about good code and bad code
there's a I would say I don't know for
generic scripts that I write just
offhand like I like 80 of it is written
by GPT just a quick quick like offhand
stuff so not like libraries not like
performing code not stuff for Robotics
and so on just quick stuff because your
basic so much of programming is doing
some
some yeah boilerplate but to do so
efficiently and quickly
because you can't really automate it
fully with like generic method like a
generic kind of
um ID type of recommendation or
something like this you do need to have
some of the complexity of language
models
I was really writing like maybe today if
I wrote like a lot of like data parsing
stuff yeah I mean I don't play ctfs
anymore but if I still play ctfs a lot
of like it's just like you have to write
like a parser for this data format like
I wonder or like admin of code
um I wonder when the models are going to
start to help with that kind of code and
they may they may and the models Also
may help you with speed yeah I'm almost
very fast
but where the models won't I my
programming speed is not at all limited
by my typing speed
and in very few cases it is yes if I'm
writing some script to just like parse
some weird data format sure my
programming speed is limited by my
typing speeds what about looking stuff
up because that's essentially a more
efficient lookup right you know
when I was out when I was at Twitter I
tried to use uh chatgpt to uh to like
ask some questions like what's the API
for this and it would just hallucinate
it would just give me completely made up
API functions that sounded real
uh what do you think that's just a
temporary kind of stage
you don't think you'll get better and
better and better in this kind of stuff
because like it only hallucinates stuff
in in the edge cases yes if your
engineering code it's actually pretty
good yes if you are writing an absolute
basic like react app with a button it's
not gonna hallucinate sure
no there's kind of ways to fix the
hallucination problem I think Facebook
is an interesting paper it's called
Atlas and it's actually weird the way
that we do uh language models right now
where all of the uh information is in
the weights and the human brains don't
really like this it's like a hippocampus
and a memory system so why don't llms
have a memory system and this there's
people working on them I think future
llms are going to be like smaller but
are going to run looping on themselves
and are going to have retrieval systems
and the thing about using a retrieval
system is you can cite sources
explicitly um
which is a really helpful to integrate
the human into the loop of the of the
thing because you can go check the
sources and you can investigate so
whenever the thing is hallucinating you
can like have the human supervision so
that's pushing it towards level two kind
of that's going to kill Google
wait which part when someone makes an
llm that's capable of citing its sources
it will kill Google
LM that's citing the sources because
that's basically a search engine
that's what people want in a search
engine but also Google might be the
people that build it maybe I put ads on
it